Ngày hôm nay, thằng trên, toàn thành phố Parry Twin Phát cụ tổng thống pháp,
ông đi của la sắc cư gì, năm 2014,
vì tôi em yêu phạm pháp,
liên quan tài việc tiêm tiêm tài trợ từ li
cho trên dịch tránh cụ năm 2020,
đây là lần đầu tiên một cụ tổ thống pháp thời hậu trên bị kết an tu ra.
Mà nâng được lạnh giá là nặng hơn nhiều dự doan và có hiệu lực ngay lập tất.
Tuy vầy, ông xác cư gì vẫn có một tháng để thủ sép đổi từ trước khi phát triển an an.
Truyền thống phát soviet ông có thể bị giám tại nhà tu lấy sáng tế,
và phàry, rồi toàn ông xác cư gì vẫn còn phát quyết là tài tiến,
thật định vô tổ ý và tình vô sẽ khảm gáo,
ông nói nếu họ muốn tối mù trong tụt, tôi sẽ làm điều đó,
nhưng vời từ thế, ngần cao đầu,
và ông và cá là bù đi cụ có mắt tại phên toàn để hủ hậu cho trong.
Tại phên tuên an, thần phát soviet không có bằng trứng ông xác cư gì trước tiếp nhận tiền
từ câu lạnh đạo của li ông, Wang Mà, gà đà phía.
Tuy nhiên ông xác cư gì bị quyết chắc hiệu, thì hỗ lạnh đạo chỉ đạo,
khiến thuộc cấp thân tiền liên lạc với giới trước khi bì nhằm xin tại trở.
Này của họ lý giò ông được tuyên trằng an với cá cậu buộc khác như thầm nữ
hại nhận tại trở mất thử pháp.
Phà truyền đạo về trình độc chuyến trường pháp,
về càng hiểu bài tỏ, ông hộ ông xác cư gì trong khi về càng tà,
có ở đây là mấy trưởng cho sự độc lập chuyến trị của họ hệ thầm từ pháp.